hello everyone Karen warden with some
courage the radio show were outside the
studio with filmmaker Jack Perez
screenwriter Ryan Levin of the film some
guy who kills people and we know we've
heard from you jack you're a huge
proponent of film school seems like from
various interviews what do you think of
people who are self-taught maybe they
just go on sort of street smarts or
instinct when they they don't actually
go through the whole educational process
yeah film school some people can't
afford film school and I think it's very
difficult to teach people how to be
talented so if somebody has you know
they have their own expressions if
somebody hears the music if somebody is
like a has an instinct for film whether
they started screwing around with
camcorders when they were young or
whatever or in high school then you
don't necessarily have to go to film
school to develop but though I think as
we were talking earlier i think that
there's an education period that is
necessary so at least you begin to
experiment with the medium you can do
that at home but i think what you need
to do is watch the great filmmakers I
mean don't just watch the new releases
go back and watch stuff in a variety of
genres by the great filmmakers read the
kind of books that you would get in film
school ah we're filmmakers discuss their
work and how they go about it I remember
reading a whole series and I continued
to read it where it's just it's I guess
they call it the on series but it's just
a collection of interviews or it'll be
like Scorsese on Scorsese Cronenberg on
Kronberg or mike lee i'm mike lee and
i'll just go through and it'll be
collected interviews with these
filmmakers going through there
filmography and they'll talk about many
of the questions that you asked us you
know how did you do this what were the
challenge is get an inside baseball sort
of look at the business start looking at
movies not as a viewer but you know even
through netflix watch a movie and try to
determine why a particular scene is
working for you you know why is this
moment hitting me so hard is it is it
how it was shot is the lens that was
used was the camera move is type of
lighting is it this is it the way the
scene was cut you know break it down
into its sort of components so that you
can start to develop an understanding of
how to create that in your own work
that's really what film school is and
make a lot of short films implementing
these things trying these things and you
know and usually messing up my early
films my early shorts in film school you
know sucked you know and it was only
after you know a half a dozen attempts
that I start to really begin to
appreciate and find my own technique and
what I liked and things that were
working for me and and I think that film
school does is it forces you to make a
lot of movies and look at a lot of
movies but if you have the discipline to
say you know what I can't afford it but
I'm going to look at I'm going to read
the book so i'm going to watch these
movies i'm just going to go watch
transformers i'm going to watch these
great films and I'm going to shoot a lot
of stuff and try these things then you
can have your own film school and then
when you decide okay now that I've done
that maybe now I try a little bit of
budget feature I think the mistake is to
just kind of like I don't know make a
feature because usually it's too costly
and you don't want to make all the
mistakes that you would make you're
gonna make mistakes anyway in your first
feature make them in the short film
process and then take what you learn in
to your first feature so i think that's
that's sort of my thinking is that you
don't have to do it formally but you
should create almost a program like a
training program you know for yourself
like if you co saw rocky 3 now that
that's like anything you need to see but
it's like clubber lang that mr. t
character can't afford a posh gym being
a rocky balboa being a rich you know
heavyweight so he's training you know
using you know in alleys and stuff like
that doesn't matter how you do it but
you need to go through the training
process for yourself so that when you
when you enter the ring your
you're in the best shape possible okay
I'm curious too what's the biggest
misconception positive or negative that
people have about this business this is
for both of you biggest surprise that
you've learned Wow um I think most
people are aware enough most people in
this or really who've been in LA or New
York trying their hand at this business
in whatever capacity for certain amount
of time have learned the realities I
don't think if you've been here or New
York or wherever long enough the truth
is smacked you across the face and you
neither stuck with it or you've bailed
the people that are just getting into it
those are the ones I think with the
misconceptions and I think that those
are the I think those misconceptions are
basically that if it's if what I'm doing
if the acting I'm if I'm a good actor or
if I'm a good writer or I'm a good
director then success will find me
quickly quickly being the operative word
or that you know one good script play
movie whatever is good enough and then I
can relax whereas the reality is it
doesn't ever end it's always what's next
what's next what's next and there's
obviously very few people there's your
there's a very select group of people in
any of the fields who whether
financially or artistically can take the
time to not have to worry about the next
thing
but I know plenty of people who
financially would be able to take their
time off if they wanted it but they also
are so part of this reality and part of
its paranoia that if to take that time
off would mean taking themselves out of
the game and to come back would be you
know they would have missed the boat on
certain opportunities they you know they
be old news they beat and there is a
kind of truth to that I mean is you know
you kind of strike while the iron is hot
and but you gotta keep striking and you
know you gotta put out enough you got to
put out 10 20 30 I mean I'm just
throwing out numbers but you got to put
out enough material put out enough work
enough widgets to you know to find the
one that will then help you get to the
next one but getting the next one might
not be any easier than getting the first
one so I think the biggest misconception
is all I need to do is land this thing
or sell this thing or make one quality
product and I'm good to go whereas it's
it's again it's a marathon it's it's
it's a long this is a career and it's a
long term investment which means that
one thing one successful project whether
it's successful because you sold it or
you're successful because you think it's
great doesn't guarantee anything for the
future so from there it's just a matter
of saying okay well I need to do I need
to keep going I need to any
you know the this is this is worthy sort
of not the non 925 aspect of the career
can easily slip into it just be just
taking over your life because there is
that essence of a element of I can
always be doing something some people
are I got you got you guys had a tie
west on um and and went I West said he
wrote a script in three or four days I
wanted to leap through the radio
throttle and then he said there and then
I just take the rest of the time on I
wanted to throttle them because not only
hers you know he's making these movies
and some I'm seen it some of them and I
really like some of them and I don't
care for some of them but like he's
actually getting them all made he's
writing them in three or four days and
in between I don't know what he's doing
um that is an aberration yeah that is
not an example of how things work no no
them so if anybody who who believes that
then I think there are probably people
who believe that your bubbles gonna
first really quick yeah yeah I'm sorry
no no I was I was I was you know I was
talking to a a screenwriter a very very
young screenwriter who has already
written like for screenplays and you see
the progression of they've gotten better
but he still thinks that he he's blown
away by the fact that they haven't sold
he's blown away by the fact that that he
has to do that somebody could read it
and have notes for him he's blown away
by the fact that more work might need to
be done on that or that because it's
good
is not selling and and and that to me
it's not a one-to-one make show so once
people understand that and they
understand that you got to be in it for
the long haul I think then you can kind
of start to settle in a little bit more
and obviously you'll still have that
those concerns but you know that route
wants that reality sets in leave okay
well then you know I need to put in a
lot to get maybe just a little bit out
of it but the more you do that longer